cette semaine l'actualité en Russie a
été marquée par des pogromes ça s'est
passé dans la région du coca c'est au
sud de la Russie oui le weekend dernier
plusieurs actions anti-juif plus ou
moins violentes se sont déroulé dans
plusieurs villes du sud de la Russie
alors on va voir une carte celle de
cette région donc du Caucase où il y a
plusieurs républiques musulmanes au sud
du pays en Russie en rouge on voit les
territoires où il y a eu des
manifestations et des pogrommes
anti-juifs les plus impressionnant se
sont déroulé à l'est au Dagestan c'est
un territoire on le voit sur les rives
de la maire Caspienne avec sa capitale
maratkala au début des années 2010 cette
république elle a été en proie à une
insurrection islamiste armée et les
questions liées au radicalisme religieux
et au salafisme ils reviennent
périodiquement dans l'actualité alors
samedi dernier plusieurs centaines de
manifestants se sont rassemblé devant un
hôtel de la ville de rassavot c'est au à
l'ouest pardon de la République des
rumeurs sur le réseau social tégram se
sont répandus comme quoi des réfugiés
israéliens logés dans un hôtel on a vu
ensuite des vides vidé circulé sur cette
même ressource télégram avec une foule
jetant des projectiles sur la façade du
bâtiment sur certaines de ces vidéos on
a même pu entendre les invectives de
ceux qui s'étaient rassemblés ils
appelaient les occupants de l'hôtel à se
montrer à la fenêtre on va voir un
extrait de l'une de ces vidéos amateur
filmé sur
[Musique]
place
il
il voilà pour ces images édifiantes
comment cela c'est terminé Elena bien la
police est arrivée elle a autorisé
plusieurs manifestants à entrer dans
l'hôtel pour s'assurer qu'il n'y avait
pas de juif à l'intérieur après quoi les
chaînes télégram ont relayé un écritau
de l'administration de l'hôtel qu'elle
aurait croché en bas on le voit sur
cette image on peut y lire entrée
strictement interdite aux étrangers
citoyens d'Israël aux Juifs entre
parenthèses il n'y en a pas ici 5 points
d'exclamation un autre hôtel de la ville
ensuite été la cible de ces pogromes la
foule d'hommees plutôt agressifs comme
on le voit sur ces images venait
contrôler qu'il était youuden Fry libre
de juifs comme on disait en Allemagne à
une certaine époque on s'en souvient le
lendemain les pogromes se sont étendus à
l'aéroport de la capitale du Dagestan
cette fois-ci oui plusieurs centaines de
manifestants on pris d'assaut l'aéroport
de marachkala qui a dû cesser de
fonctionner pendant plusieurs heures là
aussi sur telgram on a vu beaucoup de
ces vidéos circulé on y a vu notamment
les ametiers courir dans l'aéroport en
cherchant des juifs en provenance
d'Israël forcer des portes ils ont été
redirigés par des employés d'aéroport
terrorisés qui leur montrait une autre
direction en leur disant il n'y a pas de
juif là où on est où sont-ils où
sont-ils peut-on entendre régulièrement
sur ces vidéos alors plusieurs dizaines
d'hommes ont même investi les pistes de
la l'aéroport on en a même vu certains
grimper sur les alles d'un avion dans
leur viseur en particulier il y avait un
vol de la compagnie Red Wings en
provenance de té Aviv les passagers de
plusieurs avions dont celui-ci se sont
retrouvés bloqués pendant plusieurs
heures ce qui arrivé de téaviv ont
finalement pu être évacué par
hélicoptère dans l'une de ces vidéos on
entend ce qui est présenté comme
l'annonce du pilote de l'un de ses
avions bloqués écoutez
là mesdames et messieurs ici votre
commandant de bord veuillez rester à vos
places et ne tentez pas d'ouvrir les
portes de l'avion dehors il y a une
foule enragée qui ne sait pas d'où nous
arrivons et pourquoi il se pourrait bien
qu'il s'en prennent à nous aussi je vous
prie de rester à vos places dans l'avion
et de suivre toutes les instructions des
membres
d'équipage il faut le dire ces
événements les médias étatiques russes
ont pris du temps à le couvrir oui les
premiers reportages sur les chaînes de
télévision russe faisait surtout état
d'un retour au câ le calme pardon et
d'une reprise en main de la situation
par les autorités et au lendemain des
poromes à l'aéroport il y a eu
finalement la version officielle de
l'État russe elle a été reprise en
boucle évidemment par les médias
étatiques et les chaînes de télévision
notamment ces pogrom serait une
provocation orchestrée par l'Ukraine et
les services secrets occidentaux dixcite
cette version regardez cette chronique
elle a été diffusée le 30 octobre sur la
chaîne d'information en continu étatique
Rossia
24 des tentatives de diviser la société
russe de
l'extérieur occidentaux inamic et leurs
minion en Ukraine qui ne cachent pas le
fait qu'ils ont lancé et attisé les
désordres à l'aéroport de
Marka les événements de Markala ce sont
des technologies médiatiques
occidentales qui dirigeait la foule dont
les émotions étaient savamment attisé et
instrumentalisé on a même pas besoin de
le deviner c'est l'extrémiste et agent
de l'étranger Ilia ponomareev en fuite à
keV plus d'une fois il a déclaré sa
haine de notre pays ce sont ces [__]
de médias qui ont appelé à chercher les
passagers de
al il est mis en cause dans cet extrait
qui est c Ilia ponom mariov alors il
s'agit d'un ancien député de la Doua à
la chambre basse du parlement russe et
opposants russes réfugiés en Ukraine
donc les médias russes le mentionnent
parce qu'il a créé et financé une chaîne
télgram qui a diffusé les premiers
appels au pogrom sauf que voilà
ponomarov et l'un de ses anciens
associés ont depuis réagi ils affirment
avoir abandonner cette chaîne télégram
aux mains d'un administrateur originaire
du Dagestan réfugié en Turquie la chaîne
telgram elle-même a démenti tout lien à
l'heure actuelle avec pomarof qu'importe
selon la propagande russe tous les
chemins mènent à Kief et à ses maîtrre
occidentaux selon la rhétorique russe et
le 30 octobre au soir c'est Vladimir
Poutine qui a diffusé lui-même cette
version il présidait alors un conseil de
sécurité largement consacré à ces
événements au Dagestan regardez cet
extrait il a été diffusé dans l'une des
émissions phare d'actualité russe sur la
chaîne étatique Rossia
1 président a déclaré que les poromes à
marachkala ont été organisés depuis le
territoire de l'Ukraine par les agents
des services secrets occidentaux qui
selon Poutin ont instrumentalisé le
soutien des dagestanis à la Palestine
dans la nouvelle phase du conflit au
Proche
Orient ptine a traité Zelenski d'ordure
parce qu'il a immédiatement accusé tous
les Russes et notre soi-disant
antisémitisme
iné les événements d'hier soir à Markala
ont été organisés depuis les réseaux
sociaux à partir du territoire de
l'raine
par les AG secrs
occidentaux aujourd'hui les dirigeants
Ukrainiens sous la direction de leur
protecteurs occidentaux tent d'organiser
des porommes en Russie hors dur je ne
peux pas en dire autre chose voilà pour
ces insultes aucune preuve il faut le
dire pour ces théories pour le moins
complottistees oui des théories dans la
veine de la rétorique que véhicule
quotidiennement la Russie depuis le
lancement de l'offensive contre
l'Ukraine en février 2022 accusant
l'Ukraine et l'Occident de tous les mots
à aucun moment dans ses discours en en
fait ne sont vraiment mises en cause les
auteurs des pogromes eux-mêmes davantage
présentés comme les victimes d'une
manipulation de leur empathie envers le
peuple palestinien par l'Ukraine donc et
les occidentaux le lendemain le 31
octobre le journal télévisé du soir sur
cette même chaîne étatique russe Rossi à
1 il faisait état d'une enquête lancée
par laaduma la Chambre basse donc du
Parlement russe
regardez la DA examinera l'influence
étrangèes dans les événements au
Dagestan et les preuves d'incitation à
l'antisémitisme par les services secrets
ukrainiens et occidentaux
la Russie est prête à répondre à ceux
qui ont organisé la provocation de
l'extérieur comme à ceux qui la
soutiennent à l'intérieur du
pays je veux bien croire que parmi la
foule il y avait aussi des gens sincères
qui ont vraiment de la compassion pour
les Palestiniens nous examinerons la
situation au cas par cas mais tous ceux
qui se sont distingués hier auront ce
qu'ils
méritent voilà donc vous venez
d'entendre le chef de la République du
Dagestan qui promet qui promet malgré
tout des représailles plus de 80
personnes ont été interpellées plus de
20 risqu des poursuites pénales annonce
aujourd'hui le comité d'enquête russe le
parc et rus a ouvert une enquête pour
desésordres de masse un chef
d'inculpation passible de 15 ans de
préson c'était vu de Russie merci
beaucoup Elena Volochine pour votre
chronique